a manhunt in Tennessee is targeting two
suspects who could be linked to a string
of brazen murders and shootings in
Nashville three people have been killed
during a parent robberies in the last 12
days
Jayme San Antonio and Bartley teal died
in the latest attack David Pegg knows at
the scene of that double murder David
good morning Nora good morning this is
an important story that tourists and
locals need to know about we are in East
Nashville this is a trendy area a
hotspot for locals and that is the cobra
bar Friday morning two people who you
just mentioned walk outside the bar they
headed up the street to a convenience
store it was about 3:00 a.m. on their
way back police say they were shot in
the back corner of the parking lot where
those flowers and that one candle is now
there are the two victims Bartley he
died on his 33rd birthday
police believe this surveillance image
shows one of the alleged suspects
standing next to a small black Chevrolet
official suspect that two men killed
thirty year old Jamie Sir Antonio and 33
year old Bartley teal early Friday
morning the two victims left the kobra
bar at 3:00 a.m. they walked to a nearby
convenience market to purchase snacks
after buying the snacks ser Antonio and
teal walked back to the bar parking lot
where they along with another man and
woman were confronted by the alleged
suspects mr. teal was told that it was a
robbery he reportedly said he had
nothing to give
he was then fatally shot a short time
thereafter miss Aaron Tino was shot
according to police the men dumped the
victims belongings in a remote alley
because of where these items were dumped
it is quite likely that these killers
have some knowledge of this north
Nashville area police think that
Friday's killings could be connected to
a string of Nashville area shootings
last week 31 year-old Kendall rice was
shot and killed while he was walking to
a bus stop on August 8th a 39 year old
woman was shot in the back while she was
walking her dogs and she's now paralyzed
she's the wife of a crew member for the
band OneRepublic she is now in a
wheelchair and going through multiple
surgeries and has a long long road to
recovery
police have not connected any of the
crimes however the victims all of them
have similar stories John that woman who
was walking her dog and shot she
apparently walking at midnight sees a
car pass her by then that same car comes
driving back by her and that's what she
gets shot David thanks a lot some puzzle
pieces there